[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24
conmemoramos 25 años de la plataforma de
acción de beijing una resolución
histórica que fue adoptada por naciones
unidas al final de la cuarta conferencia
mundial sobre la mujer en beijing en
1995 la plataforma es a la fecha el plan
más completo del empoderamiento femenino
representantes de 189 países prometieron
lograr la igualdad de derechos y
oportunidades para todas las mujeres y
niñas del planeta
esta conferencia mundial logró una
asistencia sin precedentes y con un
único objetivo la igualdad de género 25
años después los países y las
organizaciones se han movido en esa
dirección pero aún en ninguna nación
puede decir que alcanzó la igualdad de
género este aniversario es un llamado
para el cambio
eran mediados de la década de los 90 la
capital china fue elegida como sede de
la cuarta conferencia de naciones unidas
por los derechos de la mujer y la
asistencia fue abrumadora 30.000
activistas y 17.000 participantes
incluyendo representantes de 189 países
sostuvieron dos semanas de debate
político y negociaron compromisos que
hoy son considerados históricos porque
marcaron la hoja de ruta hacia la
igualdad de género fueron cuando se les
garantice igualdad de oportunidades
elección y acceso a recursos la
participación plena de las mujeres
multiplicará la capacidad de la sociedad
como un todo site y la conclusión de la
conferencia fue la declaración y la
plataforma de acción de beijing el plan
más progresista a la fecha para promover
los derechos de la mujer se examinaron
problemas mundiales que siguen siendo
urgentes y que limitan y dañan a la
mujer como la pobreza el medio ambiente
la violencia de género la educación la
participación en el mercado laboral
[Música]
además las líderes en beijing se
comprometieron a fomentar un reparto
equilibrado de las responsabilidades
domésticas y el trabajo remunerado entre
mujeres y hombres el proceso de beijing
desencadenó voluntad política y
visibilidad mundial nunca antes tantas
mujeres habían ocupado cargos políticos
contando con protección jurídica contra
la violencia de género y viviendo al
amparo de constituciones que garantizan
la igualdad de género pero el cambio es
lento y aún hoy ningún país puede decir
que alcanzó la igualdad de género
vamos a conversar del tema y que mejor
que hacerlo con una de las mujeres que
estuvieron presentes durante los
acuerdos de beijing nos acompaña desde
lima perú tarcila rivera sea activista
de los derechos de las mujeres y pueblos
indígenas desde hace más de 40 años es
miembro del foro permanente de la onu y
actual integrante del comité
internacional de futuros de la educación
de la unesco dar así la bienvenida a
ellos hoy y usted estuvo entre las miles
de mujeres que se dieron cita hace 25
años en beijing tenía 44 años y su
activismo no ha parado desde entonces
cuáles son las grandes victorias de
beijing + 25
desde la perspectiva de las mujeres
indígenas
mi valoración es que hemos ganado mucho
hemos estado transitando desde el
movimiento indígena o sea el movimiento
mixto por la reivindicación de nuestros
derechos y también nos hemos insertado
desde el plano local e internacional al
movimiento de mujeres que luchan por los
derechos en ese sentido el proceso de
las conferencias mundiales sobre la
mujer ha ido en aumento con la
participación de las mujeres indígenas
mirando hacia atrás podría decir que
nosotras hoy tenemos una gran claridad
como mujeres indígenas que con una
conciencia de actores políticas entonces
hemos logrado por ejemplo
y hacernos escuchar
y ser aceptadas en espacios donde no
estábamos presentes y con nuestras
propuestas pero también con una mirada
que recién ahora se habla mucho sobre la
interculturalidad nosotras nunca hemos
sido excluyentes sino al contrario
siempre hemos abierto puertas y
corazones en ese sentido pues ahora
podemos decir que logramos afirmar
nuestra conciencia de derecho individual
como mujer pero basado en la conciencia
de mujeres indígenas que tienen derechos
colectivos yo sé es una de las primeras
constataciones y que queremos que
trascienda es que tenemos derechos
individuales y colectivos que son
indivisibles
sin embargo tarcila el cambio es muy
lento aún ningún país del mundo alcanza
la igualdad de género que es lo que nos
frena porque no avanzamos más
es que los prejuicios lamentablemente se
han convertido en prácticas culturales
entonces el machismo no me gusta decir
la palabra pero es real el patriarcado y
el uso del poder con esos dos conceptos
es terrible entonces siempre estamos
pensando en defender y cuidar ese
pequeño poder
y muchas veces mal usado entonces
tenemos muchas barreras todavía porque
no sé no sé a desprejuiciado ni de
colonizado el hecho de creer que las
mujeres somos menos que los varones o
que no merecemos los mismos espacios o
no o no tenemos las mismas capacidades
entonces eso hace que justamente las
personas que tienen que decidir en la
distribución de la economía en el
en las políticas públicas no estén
todavía mirándonos ni midiendo en
derechos iguales para hombres y mujeres
y esto lamentablemente tiene sus inicios
de siglos no entonces tenemos que mirar
creo de una manera diferente acerca del
rol de los miembros de la familia en
muchas culturas indígenas cuando se
habla por ejemplo de la igualdad de
género no estamos hablando hombre-mujer
es la necesidad de mantenerse en
equilibrio en la relación de unos y
otros y esto también es aplicable por
ejemplo para nosotros en relación a los
o al contexto en el que estamos viviendo
con la naturaleza los recursos naturales
los animalitos el uso de la tierra el
uso de las plantas y la relación entre
nosotros como familias o sea los niños
tienen un rol
los adultos mayores por los
conocimientos que tienen entonces lograr
una relación en equilibrio es un desafío
muy grande hay esfuerzos no gratuitos
porque la hemos luchado en las calles y
en las en los escenarios en todo nivel
pero falta mucho y creo que tenemos que
incidir bastante en el contenido del
sistema educativo público en nuestros
países porque es desde ahí desde
pequeñitos desde el hogar pero también
desde el aula que educa forma tenemos
que hacer que los derechos humanos para
todas y todos sea el estándar que
debemos
y transmitir a los niños y a las nuevas
generaciones y cada vez más estamos
demostrando que que todas tenemos las
mismas capacidades si es que tenemos las
oportunidades de crecer también en
buenas condiciones
bueno társila nadie puede negar la
importancia histórica que tienen los
acuerdos de beijing pero eso fue hace 25
años entonces yo le tengo que preguntar
porque ha pasado tanto tiempo desde que
sucede un encuentro que sea tan
fundamental para los derechos de la
mujer
lamentablemente cada cierto tiempo
tenemos nuevos cambios nuevas agendas y
entonces
las prioridades van cambiando y sin
embargo por ejemplo desde beijing
nosotras como mujeres vemos el escenario
de cuando estuvimos los o de los como se
llama los objetivos de m los objetivos
de desarrollo del milenio
pasaron los años y llegamos a la
conclusión que no se logró ahora estamos
en el contexto de la de los de ese o sea
los sobre objetivos de desarrollo
sostenible los de ese que es una agenda
al 2030 y ahí vemos que los estados se
comprometen pero los avances en su
implementación de esos compromisos a
nivel nacional es muy limitado entonces
queda todavía mucho trabajo queda mucho
por hacer nosotros quisiéramos que los
mecanismos de la mujer por ejemplo en
cada país nos incluya con programas y
presupuestos y políticas específicas
para la para la gran diversidad de
mujeres que están todavía en la agenda
pendiente y cuyos derechos no están
siendo reconocidos ni respetados uno de
los mayores temas de discusiones dentro
de beijing y a lo largo de los años ha
sido el de las violencias para finalizar
quiero preguntarle ustedes cómo evalúa
este fenómeno
la violencia en todo sentido está más
bien mucho más fuerte o no sé si más
visible y es algo que necesitamos
ponerle ojo poner atención porque no
puede ser que estemos todos los días
hablando de feminicidios de
desapariciones de persecuciones de
asesinatos de violaciones de niñas niños
y jóvenes en la trata o sea todo esto
merece atención y desde la perspectiva
indígena nosotros consideramos que la
inversión en las mujeres garantiza
justamente la salud y la y el equilibrio
en las familias entonces porque nos
consideramos generadoras de vida
entonces si esto es compartido por las
mujeres en general y por los varones que
son partidos por nosotras yo creo que
tiene que haber
una especie de justicia moral y ética en
la implementación de políticas para
acceder a mejor calidad de vida para
todas y todos a veces a usted tarcila
rivera activista de los derechos de las
mujeres y en nuestros televidentes que
continúe la implementación y la lucha
por los derechos de las mujeres sigan
con nosotros en france 24
[Música]